SPARKY RHODE: Again,
it's Wednesday
afternoon here in Europe.
And it's time for the Android
Developers Office Hours.
I'm Sparky in Munich, Germany
I'm joined by Rich and Matt in
London, UK.
Rich and--
RICH: [LAUGH]
SPARKY RHODE: Nick.
I'm sorry.
NICK BUTCHER: No
Matt this week.
Matt's off in Amsterdam,
I think it.
RICH: Yeah, J-something
conference.
I do have a conference
in Holland.
SPARKY RHODE: Matt in
a really, really
convincing Nick costume.
RICH: [LAUGH]
very good.
Hi there from England as well
and welcome to this week's
office hours.
As usual, we won't be talking
about anything that's not
previously been announced,
but fortunately--
NICK BUTCHER: Things that
have been announced!
SPARKY RHODE: [CHEER]
RICH: Finally.
We almost pre-announced it two
weeks ago when this started
ringing in my pocket.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
It's like oh no, no, no, no.
Let's not do that.
But we didn't.
And now we are free to talk
about some of the awesome new
Android devices that are
available on the Play Store.
SPARKY RHODE: But since you are
all developers, you'd much
rather talk about developing and
writing apps than the new
devices, right?
RICH: Well, I'm glad you said
that, Sparky, because there's
some amazing new APIs as
well in Android 4.2.
I hope that we'll be able to
touch on those over the next
hour as well.
Welcome to all the people to
join us in the Hangout live.
Good to see some familiar faces,
and some new ones, and
Jelly Bean, a piece of art.
I guess we should get started.
Does anyone in the
Hangout have any
questions for us today?
AL SUTTON: My one's kind
of a big can of worms.
How's multi-user handled with
respect to external storage?
RICH: OK, so first of all, Al,
congratulations on a changing
your lower third.
I see that you're a member of
Ouya, the Kickstarter Android
console gaming awesomeness that
hopefully we will all be
using soon.
Multi-user--
[INAUDIBLE] straight
into one of the new
features of Android 4.2.
On the Nexus 10, it comes
with multi-user support.
We have.
I do have multi-user on here
at the moment, I can switch
between two of my profiles.
Regarding external storage?
AL SUTTON: Yeah a lot of people
have been using it just
basically as a temporary dump
area for large files.
And a lot of applications
I've seen do that.
What happens if you've got the
same application that's
running under two
different users?
Is the application going to see
the same area for those
two users, and hence--
NICK BUTCHER: No, each
user will see a
different view of the data.
So if you [? ask for ?] get
external storage, it'll
actually get returned
[INAUDIBLE].
AL SUTTON: Cool, cool.
So we've got user separation
at that level.
NICK BUTCHER: I believe that the
hard coded string/SD card
has been grandfathered
in as well.
So if you were doing it wrong,
like please don't do that, but
I think we've catered
for that as well.
RICH: But at the same time,
each app will only be
installed on some device.
So if you do install an
application and then another
user goes to install
it, it will just
instantly be installed.
So you don't have to duplicate
all actual application and
app's data.
It's just the user specific data
that will go into their
our own private area.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, from a
developer point of view, it
should be transparent to you,
like, you shouldn't have to
write any special code for
handling multiple users.
AL SUTTON: Cool, so when you've
got two users, will
each user see the applications
the other one's installed?
RICH: No.
You get to go and install
the application.
If it is already installed, it
will just enable it for you,
but you don't get to see what
the person has installed, no.
SPARKY RHODE: Cool, thanks.
I appreciate that.
I remember, back in the day, we
had semi proprietary fork
of Eclipse that could only be
installed per user on Windows
NT, Windows 32, NT,
XP, whatever.
And man, installing Eclipse
separately for every user
account that you
wanted it on--
ouch.
I'm glad we don't
have to do that.
RICH: OK, anything else so I
have and welcome to whoever
just joined us.
I heard a ping.
No?
NICK BUTCHER: Everyone catch
the announcements this week
about Android 4.2 and the
Nexus 4, Nexus 10?
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
Anyone planning on
picking one up?
Yeah.
RICH: Just nods generally
across the
bottom of the Hangout.
They're like yeah,
I'll pick one up.
Price points are very, very
competitive, I've got to say.
AL SUTTON: And the resolution
on the 10 seems incredible.
Is it really noticeably
crisper than
other 10 inch tablets?
NICK BUTCHER: Text rendering,
for me, is beautiful.
SPARKY RHODE: My favorite
example is, I bring up a
reader app, like, for instance,
"The Economist," and
I pull up the exact same article
on the Nexus 10 and
one of the older generation,
like a Zune or a Galaxy tab.
And just look at the rendering
of the article on those two
tablets side by side, and
you'll be convinced.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: I mean, we're almost
up to print ppi's now.
It's incredible.
NICK BUTCHER: If you look
at Roman [? Gi's ?]
latest post, I think, at the
moment, he's got a photo of
the corner of the screen.
And you wouldn't believe
that it's not
superimposed image on top.
It's just phenomenal.
And yeah, it's that good.
AL SUTTON: OK, that's
one sale made.
[LAUGH]
AL SUTTON: Another
quick question--
do you know anything about
the 4.2 running
on the Nexus 7 itself.
Is there a 3G version
being made?
RICH: Hold on a second.
There are just jump
on a mute here.
Go on, just say that
again please, Al?
AL SUTTON: The 3G version of
the Nexus 7 was announced.
I don't know if you guys have
had a chance to play with it,
but is it in the territory
where you get
multi-user on it?
Or is it considered a non-tablet
device, and you
don't get multi-user.
SPARKY RHODE: I think it's not
running multi-user right now.
RICH: The only device I know
of that's got multi-user at
the moment is the Nexus 10.
I haven't seen it on the Nexus
7, but it's a good question.
I will try and resolve
that for you.
AL SUTTON: Thanks.
RICH: In the chat window down
the side, Patrick has-- oh no,
someone before that.
Francisco, "What do you think
about the battery life of the
Nexus 10 and the Nexus 4?
Thanks." Taking those
separately, Nexus 10 has got
an insanely long standby life.
NICK BUTCHER: I think you leave
it for three months on
standby, someone told me once.
RICH: Someone did
mention that.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know
if they've tested that.
I definitely haven't done
that [? one. ?]
But based on the draw
and the capacity--
RICH: Yes.
Generally, have very, very, good
battery lives, very large
batteries in them, and good
power efficiency from the
chips we're seeing.
And then Nexus 4 we've both been
using as our main phones
for a while now, and--
NICK BUTCHER: We're
not at DroidCon.
RICH: We're not at DroidCon.
Bigger batteries than all the
previous Nexus handset
devices, and more efficient
operating system, has made,
for me, a device that easily
gets through a day.
But we'll just have to see, when
you pick yours up, what
you think about them.
NICK BUTCHER: And silly things,
like the inductive
charging is amazing.
So I have an inductive charger
on my desk and
on my bedside table.
And so every time I sit down, I
just put the phone down, and
it's charging.
So it stays charged because
it's so easy.
I don't have to think about
plugging it in and or
unplugging it when I get
up, I just put it
down, and pick it up.
AL SUTTON: Does the 10 have
inductive charging as well?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
AL SUTTON: Only the 4.
NICK BUTCHER: Just the four.
RICH: So mine's currently set at
82% full after 6 hours and
14 minutes without any charge.
Not that you can see that,
but it's doing
very well right now.
SPARKY RHODE: I mean, really the
make or break is whether
it gets through a day, right?
RICH: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: I haven't had that
problem with it yet.
I was concerned about switching
to a device that
doesn't have a removable
battery, but the tradeoff
being that it has a bigger
battery inside it.
And of course, it has inductive
charging coils
somewhere in the back.
I can switch in between the
back and the battery.
And I've been happy with it.
NICK BUTCHER: I love mine.
RICH: No issues, yeah,
I love mine too.
AUDIENCE: What's the inductive
charging like?
Is it just as quick, well,
obviously, it won't be as
quick, but is it still pretty
speedy compared a cable?
NICK BUTCHER: I don't
really know.
Yeah, I think so.
I tend to leave it put down
overnight, and it's charged.
Yeah, I don't know, if you were
just going to put it down
for an hour, would it
do a full battery
charge, I'm not sure.
RICH: I really want someone to
bring a really nice range of
furniture with inductive
charging built into it.
Coffee tables with little
inductive charging points in
the colors and things, that you
can just, you don't have
to have these wires around.
AL SUTTON: Nokia did a pillow
for their Lumia
for inductive charging.
And you kind of sit there and
think, like, what would you do
carrying this phone
around on pillow.
It looks like something from
the royal household, yeah.
RICH: So yeah, the other thing
is, the games on the Nexus 10
look amazing.
Oh, that's great.
I saw the EA games "Mass Effect
Infiltrator" and "Need
for Speed: Most Wanted," just
look inside at 2500.
And the scary thing is, when
you use the HDMI out, or
wireless display, it has to
scale down for a full HDTV.
Scale it down to 1080p.
So it's absolutely flying
as well, very good
frame rates on it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I've got a
massive 30 inch monitor at my
desk, and it's got the same
resolution as that--
RICH: 10 inch tablet.
NICK BUTCHER: On a
10 inch tablet.
RICH: The A15 chip cooks.
Not in a hot way.
NICK BUTCHER: Love it.
RICH: Yeah.
OK, let's do some development
questions, unless there's one
more in the--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
in the sidebar.
Patrick, I'm pronouncing it
right, a question about screen
sharing in 4.2.
"Will it require some kind of
device in between?" So yeah,
it's based on Miracast.
Is the wireless screen sharing,
I guess that's what
you're talking about.
So if your TV supports Miracast,
which I'm not sure
if there are any out there
now, but I here it's an
emerging standard of which
people are going to adopt,
then the answer would be no.
Until then, I believe there's
a range of dongles either on
the market now or coming out
which you can use to retrofit
that Miracast support into
your existing TV.
So yeah, right now the answer
is, probably most people will
have to buy some kind of
dongle to do that.
But in the future, hopefully no
additional devices required.
RICH: Yeah, you mentioned
standards like DLNA, but
usually they just do media
streaming, sharing videos and
audio, they won't allow
entire desktop
sharing off of the device.
Whereas this is, you can do
mirroring, or you can send a
separate stream to the
second screen.
Now in Android 4.2, with the
second screen APIs, you get
notified when a second screen's
plugged in connected,
and you can send a completely
separate set of
views to that screen.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and the cool
thing is that DLNA piggy
backs on a network, whereas
Miracast, I believe, is built
on top of the Wi-Fi, so you can
have a direct connection
between, say, your TV and your
device without having to have
another Wi-Fi access
point in between,
which is kind of cool.
SPARKY RHODE: Ah, I see Pavel
has asked us an actual
programming question.
"What is the density, screen
size bucket or N10, and will
we see more buckets introduced
in the near future?" Correct
me if I'm wrong--
I believe it will be an extra
large XHDPI, is that right?
Correct.
And as of API level 16, there
exists a constant for XXHDPI,
but we haven't really
done a lot with it.
NICK BUTCHER: So I heard a post
on Google+ yesterday,
which some people might've seen,
saying that yes, the
tablet is an x-large
XHDPI screen.
But launcher tablet devices
picks a launcher icon for your
app from one density bucket up,
so that it can render it
slightly larger and
see a larger icon
and on the home screen.
So for that reason, yeah, you
need to provide an XXHDPI icon
in order to get a really
beautifull crisp icon.
AL SUTTON: I got a kind of
development question.
It's one that you might not be
able to answer, so do you know
when the 4.2 SDK is going
to be available?
NICK BUTCHER: Generally,
historically, it tends to get
shipped when we launch a device,
or open source, or
erase the factory image.
So historically, that's
what's happened.
So when that happens, I guess.
But I don't have a date.
RICH: OK, yes you'll
see XXHDPI.
NICK BUTCHER: Where
will it end?
SPARKY RHODE: I believe
that's nominally 480
dpi, is that right?
480, yeah.
That's nothing.
Actually XX is just a redirect
for a number.
I think it gets even turned
into 480 dpi by our APTT.
By our APT.
So you can actually just
use drawable-480 dpi.
Rather, than drawable
expectations.
There's nothing like being
prepared for the future.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, although,
a couple of benefits, it's
like, where is it going to end
if you keep on adding X's.
It's kind of silly.
But the other thing
is also, make sure
resources, nice and ordered.
In a clutch.
RICH: Does anyone what the
dpi of the HTC was?
SPARKY RHODE: The actual,
I think, was more 440.
RICH: OK, so it's still
not quite 480.
But that said, I mean,
these are all
kind of elastic ranges.
So it may very well be that
something with an actual
density of 440 might sort
into 480 bucket anyway.
And it might be an XX.
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
RICH: Right on.
One of the other nice features
of 4.2 is, when you're
developing for multiple screens,
you can put a virtual
second screen on your device and
see what we it will render
like inside your application.
So in the developer settings,
there's now a new setting,
which I'll bring up, in the
developer options for--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this is
one of the APIs I'm really
excited about, actually having
an actually API to draw things
separately to a secondary
screen.
So you can have your game
controllers on your phone, and
the game output up
on your big TV.
RICH: You can't really see it,
but you can simulate a second
screen here on the side
of your screen.
And the second screen would be
what appears onto the TV set
or the other screen that
you connect it to.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so you can
develop against that without
having to have second
screens and stuff.
SPARKY RHODE: So now how long do
we have wait for Nexus DS?
RICH: [LAUGH]
What's that?
I don't get it, Sparky.
NICK BUTCHER: Dual screen.
RICH: Oh, is that what DS stood
for in the Nintendo.
I never knew that.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
RICH: Go figure.
OK, so should we hit the
Moderator and get on with some
of the questions
for this week?
NICK BUTCHER: Unless-- we've
got a few new joiners.
Any other questions from
people in the Hangout?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Can
you hear me now?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: Yeah hey, Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I had
a few questions.
First of all, I wanted to try
something with the Google
Calendar, maybe do something
very, very simple, but without
showing an intent to the user,
and basically schedule an
appointment into the calendar.
I know it's possible.
I saw some code.
But is it considered a good
convention, or I must show the
user the exact appointment
I'm scheduling?
NICK BUTCHER: It depends,
really.
Like if you have a screen,
basically, showing the same
information that would go into
the create event screen, then
I think it's fine to just have
that within your UI, and have
that add to [? calendar ?]
[? or just ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
If you're just basically
recreating what the calendar
UI shows, then I would
probably say
just use the intent.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: The basic idea
was to just use the calendar
as a sort of time stamp for
actions you do, like, went to
the market, 10:15, answer
the phone, 10:20, and
so on, and so on--
just use it as a time stamp
for all events you want to
record on your--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so
you probably would
create your own calendar.
So you probably wouldn't want to
write those into the user's
kind of like Google [INAUDIBLE],
or whatever, you
want to create your
own [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever calendar.
And then create your events in
that so then the user can
wholesale, turn that calendar
on and off and hide and show
those events.
I think it probably sounds
like a good solution.
There's actually a great article
on Rockin' Android, if
you know that blog.
By Wolfram, yeah, he's just been
doing a couple of posts
lately about working
with the calendar.
So I encourage you to
check those out.
RICH: And I actually had an
example right, when you pinned
an item from the conference
to fit it into
your calendar as well.
Yeah, there's a sample code in
the Goolge I/O app as well.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK, I'll
check it, thanks.
RICH: I just wonder what you
guys thought of the photo
sphere that you've been
seeing on Google+.
Did you see Hugo's video on how
to create a Photosphere
from outside building 44?
AUDIENCE: I saw yours.
You put two up, didn't you?
RICH: Yeah, I did a couple more
last night as well, but I
haven't posted them yet.
I might do one from this
Hangout, so you can get to see
everything in the room.
And then--
[LAUGHTER]
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
what are we both looking out--
there'd be a big blank thing.
It's a good point.
I could do one--
NICK BUTCHER: Censored.
RICH: Oh no, I could just
do a 2/3 photosphere.
That's a photo hemisphere?
OK, I'm just looking through
the what's new for Android
4.2, and of course
photospheres is
right at the top.
SPARKY RHODE: So you guys know
that the right way to make
photosphere is not to turn
your body around, right?
If you do sort of swivel your
body around and move the phone
in a cylinder, you're going to
get parallax effects that make
for bad stitching.
If you want it to stitch
properly, you need to actually
pivot the camera around the
focal point of the lens.
RICH: But then you're going to
get your own face in it.
[INAUDIBLE] head.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
RICH: Well, I don't know.
Honestly I think it's good to
depend on how far away the
thing is that you're making
the photosphere of.
So the ones I've taken from
very large buildings and
outside don't seem to have
a problem, I guess.
But the ones I've taken in
the office maybe have
more of that from--
you have to be slight more
careful taking it.
SPARKY RHODE: That's
exactly right.
The parallax is way worse
on nearby objects.
RICH: Yes, exactly.
OK, can we move to the
moderator now?
Excellent.
SPARKY RHODE: I have not had as
much time to go through the
Moderator this week
as I usually do.
Fortunately, some of the other
readers have done it for me.
RICH: Yeah, thanks Chris.
Cheers, guy.
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE]
giving some answers.
So thanks, Chris, yes.
"I'm running an app that listens
to incoming SMS, and
if the SMS contains special
text, I want to prevent it
from being received by a
third-party apps, eg Handset.
I tried abort broadcast and
setting Android priority.
It didn't work.
How can I do this?"
And Chris basically said that
these other applications all
set their receivers to maximum
priority, which
means they get it first.
So there's no way you can
deterministically jump in line
in front of them.
In other words, sorry, but no.
So no.
NICK BUTCHER: Unless you
want to overflow int.
RICH: Unless you--
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE]
Moderator is a question
from Nick Butcher.
It's not really a question.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, sorry, I put
that in there because we had a
problem with the GDL event,
and we couldn't
update it with the links.
So I added it in the moderator,
so it would appear
on the right page.
SPARKY RHODE: And it did the job
because, without that, I
wouldn't be here.
"Is there a way to alter the
standard font used, say,
Roboto light, across a whole
application, including action
bar, et cetera, or do you have
to do this manually in each
activity and fragment." And he
also says, "Changing the font
is fairly difficult, Jelly Bean
allows you to use Roboto
light condensed via the new
font family XML attribute.
Pre-Jelly Bean, it creates
a [INAUDIBLE] code."
Then he goes on to say, "I'd
like to create a custom text
view and override set typeface
to inject your custom font,
then use that text view instead
of the standard one."
I don't know.
Nick, what do you
think of that?
RICH: I don't know a better
way of doing it across the
entire application in
one fell swoop.
NICK BUTCHER: You could do it
in Jelly Bean not too bad.
You could basically use
the style-- create a
custom style, right?
Where you find out where the
where font family is set and
override it.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, to using
the font family thing.
But to retrofit that onto a
pre-Jelly Bean world, yeah
it's not going to be easy.
SPARKY RHODE: I know last week
I talked about sticking
animate layout attributes in
the style at the top level.
Would this work, or this
not work for that?
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah, that
would totally work in the
post-Jelly Bean world where you
can set the font family
attribute for the
entire thing.
But in pre-Jelly Bean, before
the font family attribute, no.
But why would you ever
want to do that.
I think part of the reason an
action and everything is good
is because it's familiar.
If you start wholesale changing
everything-- is this
your question, Chris.
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Another Chris in
London, and then answered by
another Chris in London.
Or there's a conversation with
yourself, perhaps, going on.
SPARKY RHODE: What can I
say, I'm schematically.
I'm an engineer,
not an artist.
And I would never want to
screw with the stock UI.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: I just want the
app to do what it does.
I don't care what
it looks like.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this
is setting off
alarm bells, this question.
Question why you need to
do this, is my advice.
SPARKY RHODE: OK Peter in
Belgium says, "I'm integrating
a plus 1 button.
But I want to use a
token returned by
google.authutil.getToken with
one of the scopes--
googleapis/on/plus.mean.
But a first plus 1 interaction
still shows an extra
authorization dialogue.
Is this possible?" I presume
he means is it possible to
show it without getting--
RICH: To reuse the auth token,
yeah, so they don't need to
get the second authorization
dialogue.
Um, I'm slopey shoulders that
straight up to the Google+
developer office hours.
They manage their own APIs,
and libraries and things.
I haven't put a plus 1
button in my app yet.
I know, right?
Why [INAUDIBLE] put a plus one
button for your whole app?
You're supposed one button on
the things that have real
world URLs.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
You can plus 1 the whole app,
and it would plus 1 the app
the listing in Play Store.
NICK BUTCHER: The Play
Store URL, yeah.
RICH: But I think it would be
more beneficial to if you had
a recipes app, and you were plus
1-ing the recipes, and
the recipes on the
web [INAUDIBLE]
because then, someone sees the
plus 1 in Google+, and they
can click on it.
And there's somewhere
to go to.
NICK BUTCHER: Got it.
RICH: I don't know.
Makes more sense.
NICK BUTCHER: Plus
1 all the things.
RICH: Haven't tried
it, thought.
Plus one-ing your app with the
Play Store URL, though, seems
like a very good thing
to do too, though.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I can see
that being in your about
screen also.
And if you had some kind
of screen like that?
You could have a
little plus 1.
Well, this is speculation, of
course, because we haven't
actually tried it.
Google+ Developer Office
Hours from
developers.google.com/live.
SPARKY RHODE: That's right.
We've got a couple of new
people in the Hangout.
Welcome newcomers.
Do you have anything that you'd
like to bring up for
discussion?
RICH: I recognize Leslie there
in the purple shirt.
Good to see you, any questions
this week, Leslie?
No, yes.
No, OK.
Anyone else?
OK?
Next muffin.
SPARKY RHODE: "Are there best
practices or guidelines for
using Roboto light, Sans Serif
light font family in the app,
combining with other
font families.
For instance, using a light font
family for headers, big
text, and normal for
ordinary text.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
physically sick.
NICK BUTCHER: So we don't have
any official guidelines yet.
It's something I'd like
to see us lead on
a little bit better.
In my personal opinion, I
like it for big text.
I like headers, like say there,
I think that it can
work really well if you provide
some contrast and
relief by using the
Roboto light.
And also if there's secondary
text as well.
So if there's a piece of
information which isn't of
primary importance, rather than
using a different font
color or the size, per se, you
can use a different weight to
give relative importance.
My caution there is using light
fonts at smaller sizes.
You might end up affecting
legibility, especially on
smaller screens.
So be cautious with
using it too much.
So I'd say stick with Roboto
normal weight for most of your
body text, as it were because
that's a font that's been
optimized for most of these
general reading operations.
And it works for a variety
of densities.
And then use something like
Roboto light or thin.
Yeah, in less often, in kind
of places to give relief.
SPARKY RHODE: So you're saying
use the lighter weight
typefaces in the larger sizes,
where they won't get
anti-aliased away.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I know from pretty much the
earliest days of WYSIWYG
topography, the general
guidance has been, use
multiple appearances in
your type sparingly--
think accent, not mishmash.
I don't know about you guys,
but there were definitely
times early on when I
was like, ooh, this
computer has 25 fonts.
I must use every one in my
documents, otherwise, I might
be missing an opportunity.
And I think the opportunity
I missed was legibility.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
Yeah, well, one of the things I
always think as well that--
a screen can get too busy if you
have multiple font sizes.
So I've seen screens where
people are trying to use the
size of font to basically
determine the importance of
the information.
So you might have like a
headline in a list item, and
then some secondary text, and
then it might be like a count
in a third font size,
and so on.
And that can get really busy if
you're basically having all
these different line heights.
Essentially, it doesn't really
scan very easily.
It's quite hard to process,
and it makes you
think about it more.
So what you can do instead is
either use color or even a
lighter font face, so you will
maintain the same kind of line
height or X height.
And just have some slight
contrast in the weight of the
font instead.
So that makes it a bit
easier to read.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, I think a
lot of HTML renders are kind
of annoying in the way they deal
with H1, H2, H3, H4, et
cetera because they do
scale in size and
weight quite a lot.
And it kind of makes for a
little busy appearance.
RICH: OK, so before we move on
to the next one, one other
nice new developer that's
come along with
Android 4.2 is the Daydream.
We now have, I guess, a similar
concept to screen savers.
When the device is plugged in
or docked, or inductively
charging, the device will
kind of go to sleep.
And you can choose what's going
to be on the screen at
that time, whether it's going
to be the weather forecasts,
or news, but, of course, your
applications can make use of
these APIs to show your
own data as well.
The user can choose to have your
own Daydream showing up
on the screen.
Right now I have one
from Currents.
SPARKY RHODE: I love
the photostream.
RICH: And you can see the--
not very well.
We definitely, when we get off
studio, I need to have the
HDMI around here.
You can interact with the
currents as well as they're
coming across onto the screen
and see all the latest news.
It just sits there, once it's
charge, giving you the latest
up to date information.
It's a similar API to
live wallpapers.
And you'll be seeing that in
the SDK when it comes out.
NICK BUTCHER: It's
called Daydreams.
Daydreams.
Is the consumer features.
I think it's just called
Dream in the SDK.
So I once the 4.2 SDK comes out,
just search for Dream.
In fact, there's already in
the compatibility SDK.
There's a basic dream in there
which you can probably take a
loot at and have a look at some
of the APIs it offers.
It's going to similar to
something like the widget.
It's this kind of pervasive
awareness.
So if your application is
updating the background and
offering up new content, it's
another way to surface that.
It's kind of cool.
If someone is like a big
football fan or something like
that, you might have transfer
new or something, whenever you
put your phone down, and it's
charging, you might just kind
of [INAUDIBLE].
It's kind of cool.
RICH: Yeah.
I've switched between having
the weather online, the
weather forecasts,
and the news.
It's quite nice just to see
things going past that you're
interested in, very configurable
as well.
What was the-- oh,
we've seen that.
OK, next.
SPARKY RHODE: Pavel's got
a question in sidebar.
He says, still no love for 3D
camera in the Nexus line.
I don't want the 3D images,
I just want to see
the depth of vision.
Interesting.
Well, I've got a lovely
LG Slate tablet
that's got 3D on it.
NICK BUTCHER: They released
an SDK for that, right?
AL SUTTON: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: It's
a proprietary--
AL SUTTON: It's quite funny that
every OEM who produced a
3D device never followed
it up with a second
device in same line.
The Optimus 3D was a one-off.
The LG Slate was a one-off.
There was an HTC phone, as
well, that was a one-off.
So I got the feeling it
didn't work well.
RICH: LG did have the second in
the Optimus 3D phone range
at Barcelona this year, I just
never really saw it launch.
But at least it was thinner.
It didn't have that
big bulk on the
back for the two cameras.
NICK BUTCHER: Still
made my brain hurt
after a little while.
RICH: Still made your brain
hurt if you looked at that
screen and didn't just freeze.
NICK BUTCHER: But yeah, if you
are really passionate about
that, I guess the things you
could do would be, petitioner
LG to contribute it to
[INAUDIBLE], perhaps.
Beyond that--
SPARKY RHODE: Well, and as
far [? just having it ?]
something, what could
you use for that?
I mean--
I don't know, maybe infer
something from focus?
That would be interesting.
Maybe just try to get the focal
distance out of the
camera API or something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm interested in getting
the device.
It's very easy to
get a device.
But I would like to see this
kind of sensor to be more
widespread.
And that's why I ask you about
this eventually being put in
the future Nexus devices because
if it's under 1% of
the market share, what's the
point of creating applications
for such type of use case.
RICH: Yeah, that's a very
valid question.
AUDIENCE: If the sensor
is everywhere, then
applications will come.
NICK BUTCHER: Petition
Mr. Rubin.
RICH: Yeah, I mean, the place
where you'd expect it to take
off first would be on the 3D
TVs, and councils, and things
like that, if it
was going to--
They've had a lot of chance
for it to happen.
As yet, it hasn't really.
My best experience with that has
been Gran Turismo 5, on a
PlayStation with a 3D TV.
That's pretty moving.
And other people in the room
jumped when we crashed.
All [? with our ?]
3D glasses on, but I think it
still needs another step
change in 3D technologies
for--
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, it's
a screen thing.
I though it was camera thing
so you can see the depth.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you can really
create amazing concept.
Like if you're typing SMS while
you're running, you can
get warning, like [INAUDIBLE]
if you are nearing an obstacle
so that you save your face,
RICH: [LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Typing an SMS
while you're running?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH: Really, Google Voice
input filter for panting.
SPARKY RHODE: [LAUGH]
RICH: And you can speak to it
whilst you're running and it
just takes your deep breathing
out of it.
AL SUTTON: I'd wait for the
Google Now card to pop up that
says, you're about to run into
something in 30 seconds.
RICH: 30 seconds?
What, if you're running
really slowly.
That moment in "Austin Powers"
where he's like, no!
And then doesn't get run over.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
Just like that.
RICH: Just like that.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Where are we
now, Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: Next question
on the Moderator.
"I'm trying to monitor the CPU
usage of running processes by
running ADD shell top.
It works well in general, but
when testing an app that plays
music, CPU usage for the process
of running the service
stays at 0%.
Also on Stack Overflow, link
included." I suppose that's
probably because it's being
handed off to hardware.
You know, keep up a sample, you
hand it off to the audio
subsystems, and the
CPU can step back.
RICH: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: Sound
right to you?
[? Tops ?] not representing the
GPU or any of the other
accelerators.
AL SUTTON: The other thing would
be, that, as well as
handing it off to the servers,
if it's not a rooted device,
ADB shell top may not show you
all the processes running.
RICH: Also true, yeah.
You won't see systems,
necessarily.
NICK BUTCHER: That's
a good point.
RICH: Yeah, it could be worth
testing on a richer devices to
see if you do get any extra
information that's relevant.
So the next one, "Could you
please suggest a way to create
a video of your app/game?" We've
had this three or four
times in the past on
the office hours.
The recommendations are buy a
Nexus 4 with Wireless Display
and an HDMI record.
SPARKY RHODE: So I just take
my phone, and I point it at
the screen, and hold still,
hold still, hold still.
RICH: So the most recent videos
I've made have been
using the hardware accelerated
an OpenGL accelerated
emulators, that seems to work
very well for me, and then
screen capturing software on
whatever system you're using
to create the video.
Otherwise, you can use
HDMI recorders and a
device with HDMI out.
That works very well as well.
Black magic has some great boxes
for that kind of thing.
But the cheapest way--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Use
two devices.
RICH: Yep, using two devices.
Taking a video of the screen
isn't ideal , of course.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, your best
results are always going to be
HDMI capture.
Second best is proably going
to be emulator and then the
easy screen capture.
RICH: Oh, it's just those.
NICK BUTCHER: Emulator also,
like blue stacks even, so you
can run it on your
host machine.
SPARKY RHODE: That's an
interesting idea.
I hadn't even thought of that.
RICH: Yeah, he suggests
Android screencast.
I agree, Android screencast.
Anything that's using ADB for
screen capturing is going to
be a little bit on the sluggish
side, maybe one or
two frames a second.
So I would probably steer
clear of that.
SPARKY RHODE: I haven't
really messed around
with blue stack, thought.
How well does it work?
RICH: Sorry?
SPARKY RHODE: The blue stacks,
how well does that work?
Because I haven't
really tried it.
RICH: Anybody?
Anybody tried blue stacks?
Al must have done.
AL SUTTON: I played around with
an early alpha version of
it, and it was a little sluggish
and a little slow.
They may have improved
it since then.
But--
RICH: You could use Andro VM.
That's what [INAUDIBLE] mobile
were talking about at DroidCon
last week, and Gen Y mobile.
NICK BUTCHER: Was it Andro
VM, was that the answer?
It's a virtual box based--
RICH: Android VM.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
AL SUTTON: And there was also
a product from a company
called Lumitrade at DroidCon,
which was kind of a cradle for
a camera that would sit over
the top of the phone.
So you could lay the phone
flat and then just record
straight from that camera.
And that's about 250
Euros, I think.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but then you
obviously get the finger
in the way.
So it depends on what want.
If you want to demonstrate
people interacting, then
that's one thing.
I quite like the product videos
which use the show
touches thing.
So if you do an HDMI app
capture, [? show ?] touches
from the developer menu, then
you get a little translucent
white dot where you're touching,
which I think comes
out quite well in
product videos.
SPARKY RHODE: I see Yossi also
has provided the URL for
androvm.org.
Thanks for that, Yossi.
And question here, "Will the
third party app widgets be
able to hoot into 4.2's new lock
screen functionality, or
is it limited to system apps?
How many possible per lock
screen, assuming we will get
[INAUDIBLE]?"
RICH: I don't think we have
a definitive answer on
that one right yet.
SPARKY RHODE: That
one's a little--
RICH: Sorry Sparky?
Sparky was just about to
answer the question.
Maybe he had the answer
before dropping out.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: The answer
was 42, no?
RICH: 42, was that the answer?
Yeah, 4.2, you've got to read
something into that.
But yes, there will be
a developer API.
You'll be able to add lock
screen widgets similar to home
screen widgets.
I haven't seen the API myself
yet, so I can't really comment
any more than that.
Moving on.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, "I'm trying to
set the scroll position in
a remote list view on an
app widget without
any scrolling animation.
Unfortunately, the usual set
section position is not
remoteable.
Any hints on how to
achieve this?
Is it even possible?" Mr.
Widgets, have you done this?
RICH: The scroll position
on a remote list
view on an app widget.
No, I have not done that.
Without any scrolling
animation.
Unfortunately [INAUDIBLE].
No, I'd have to try that out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Ask it on Stack
Overflow.
Sorry, is that Chris?
AUDIENCE: I don't
think you can.
Because the list view runs in
launcher, and so you can't
access that at all.
So I can't think of a
way you could do it.
NICK BUTCHER: But he seems to
be implying that you can
scroll it with a scrolling
animation.
AUDIENCE: I didn't think you
could that, but I don't know.
RICH: I just wonder if you can
reinitialize the widget at a
different position.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, you
can, but not without
the scrolling animation.
RICH: Can you override
the animation?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: We
didn't try that.
The best thing we did was
imitate a scrolling list.
So to avoid the scrolling
animation, we divided the
widget into three parts and
show every time we show a
different part to imitate the
scrolling, basically.
RICH: Fair enough.
Sounds like it's not
too impossible.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: "Anything new with
the action bar in 4.2?" I
don't think so.
RICH: I haven't seen it in the
what's new [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] have
to wait for the final SDK and
check the [? dif ?] again,
but I don't think so.
RICH: Nope.
OK, Sparky is going to join
us as soon as he can.
He's had some technical issues
with his battery running out.
NICK BUTCHER: "Does Nexus
7 support Miracast?"
AL SUTTON: No.
It doesn't even support
HDMI out, so it
couldn't support Miracast.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: The new version
will support, no?
NICK BUTCHER: But you can
get [INAUDIBLE] support?
AL SUTTON: It's most likely
needs the HDCP keys installed.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
that's very true.
AL SUTTON: Which wouldn't be on
if it's not HDMI enabled.
So even if it did, it wouldn't
be able to display protected
content, which would stop
it playing Google
Play movies and stuff.
And it seems to be the device
of choice for doing
that kind of thing.
RICH: True, but mirroring the
screen and playing games on a
TV using the device and things
like that wouldn't require
those, necessarily.
I don't know.
AL SUTTON: I also had a look
at the Miracast list of
approved devices.
And it's not up there
at the moment.
There is currently only the
Samson Echo P TVs, which are
yet to be released, the Nexus
4, Optimus G, and Galaxy S3.
So I would say no for now.
But if a new one comes out
because the new on that's
launched for 3G has a different
power controller in
it, so it could in the future.
But I wouldn't see it as
possible in the short term.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH: Yeah, I don't
have any further
comments on it than that.
But I have lost my moderator.
NICK BUTCHER: Where
are we up to?
RICH: Next page.
"My company's developing a
Bluetooth low-energy device.
Will Android 4.2 support BLE
in the SDK?" Don't know.
I think so, haven't checked.
NICK BUTCHER: I think we have
to want till 4.2 launches to
what finally made the
cut and what didn't.
RICH: [LAUGH]
[INAUDIBLE]
"What could I do wrong.
I get an illegal state exception
with opening the
options menu.
The exception comes from
ad view in the
phone window open panel.
Did I somehow break the
activity life cycle?
More detail on Stack
Overflow."
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
RICH: You did something.
NICK BUTCHER: And it sounds
like you did.
RICH: The specified child
already has a parent.
You must call remove view
on the parent first.
NICK BUTCHER: Sounds like
you're inflating
a fragment or something.
Are you inflating, I think,
when you were doing your
inflation of something,
you're doing it wrong.
RICH: Or you're trying to
do it more than once.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm trying to
read on Rich's screen.
RICH: That's something that--
yeah, we should bounce that
one into next week's
office hours.
That kind of question we need
to get a little bit more in
advance so that we can have a
good look through the pages of
stack traces and code that
you've attached to the report.
It doesn't make for good
watching to do it lives.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, to me, my
first gut instinct is that
you're probably inflating
something that's already
attached to something else.
One of the parameters when you
call inflator.inflate, the
different XML stuff is,
you give it a parent.
And you say whether or
not to attach it.
And it sounds like you passing
a true when it's already
attached to something.
You should leave that to the
error, or maybe you should
just pass false.
So whenever your menu options
create it maybe.
RICH: Oh, we'll bounce that
one to next week.
That's fine.
Who just joined us
in the Hangout?
Hugo, hey there Hugo.
Good to see you.
Have you got a question
for us today? day
AUDIENCE: Yeah, actually
I have.
Can you hear me?
RICH: Yeah, yeah, I
can hear you fine.
Go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: I was at V-hack
this weekend.
We were hacking on a food app,
and it has a few list views
with check boxes, and I had
some problems there with
making a checkbook selected
after the data had loaded.
So I have a cursor loader, where
it has loaded some stuff
from the database.
And then I wanted to
make it selected.
And of course, it was a V-hack,
so I was hacking and
doing ugly stuff
in the adapter.
But that didn't work
on all devices
process for obvious reasons.
And then, in the end, I settled
with just unloading
the data to the cursor loader,
and then, after the data was
loaded, iterating the cursor
again to set the checked item
on the list view.
But it feels a little
bit clunky.
So I was wondering what's
the proper way to do it.
Or is this the proper
way to do it?
Because I asked around to some
other devs and they didn't
really have a proper answer.
NICK BUTCHER: So you're
extending simple cursor
adapter, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So you're using
your bind view method there.
So that will be the right place
to bind whatever the
cursor's data is to
your UI, right?
AUDIENCE: I did that, but
then it messed up.
Well, I think what happened
there is that the check boxes
are maybe selected, but the list
view itself doesn't know
it's selected for some reason.
[INAUDIBLE]
the separation that I got.
NICK BUTCHER: Did you try and
synchronize the state of the
control within the list item
with the selected state of the
entire item?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess that's
what I'm trying to do because
what makes sense is that the
because you call sets item
checked, I guess, what the
matter method is called on the
list, so that, yeah, reflects
the state, and the view also
gets updated, which
is quite nice.
And likewise, if you touch
a list item, then it's
automatically reflected
on the list?
But yeah.
I had some problems there.
So I'm not sure.
I want to generally make sure
that the list is in sync with
the adapter and those kinds of
things, especially for things
that are checked.
RICH: Yeah, so if the data in
the adapter is changing
outside of the list, then you're
got to notify the list
of what's going on.
And if the user's pressing the
item on the list, you've got
to notify the adapter, or at
least change the data set
behind it of what's going on.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, actually the
pressing on the list
automatically works.
It's nothing that you
have to do for that.
But my problem was loading the
initial values from the cursor
adapter because it loaded.
And if I would set it on the
view, for some reason, it
wouldn't reflect.
I'm not sure because
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I did something
terribly wrong.
NICK BUTCHER: What multi-set
mode are you
setting on the list?
Because it sounds like you've
got multiple items.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I set
it to multi-select.
NICK BUTCHER: So you're setting
it to multiple.
RICH: So are you loading all
the data into the list once
and then going around a second
time for all the
check boxes, then?
AUDIENCE: Well, I basically
[INAUDIBLE] on the what is it,
the onload finished?
Or I'm not sure what is
the method in the
cursor loader itself.
So what I eventually did, and
what worked on all devices was
just to iterate the cursor
again, see what's selected,
and then call list
set item checked.
But obviously, I don't
think that's the
proper way to do it.
But I wasn't sure.
NICK BUTCHER: No, my gut feeling
is you should be doing
this in bind view.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
RICH: Yeah, wait until you've
got the data before you.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'll just try it
again to see if I can figure
out what is the problem, if I
have some more time for it.
AL SUTTON: So Nick, is the
Nexus 4 made of soap?
NICK BUTCHER: That
was my 7 again.
It survived this one though.
Yeah, it survived.
[INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: So it's still an
Nexus 7, it's not a Nexus 6
and 1/2 now?
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGH]
RICH: What was that that
came in on the
chat window from Francisco.
"I want to buy the Nexus 4 but
I don't know whether to buy
now or in a couple of months."
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe Google--
SPARKY RHODE: I don't think
you can buy now.
RICH: Oh yeah, we're certainly
not going to--
and then Yossi says just
override the bind view method.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: I'd say buy now.
Like, I got the 8 gig one, and
I haven't really been butting
up against the storage limit.
I don't play tons
of big games.
Probably get a 16
gig, big enough.
RICH: I'd get a 16 gig.
SPARKY RHODE: Are you talking
about the Nexus 7?
RICH: Nexus 4s.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh, OK.
Because I do have the
8 gig Nexus 7.
And it's only got about six
gigs of user accessible
storage, and that goes fast.
I mean, I think I've got
probably four games, each of
which has more than a gig and
a half of extra data.
So there you go.
There's your storage.
RICH: Yeah, totally.
I'm running a 16 gig Nexus 7,
and I've got an 8 gig Nexus 4
as well, actually,
and I haven't had
any issues with it.
But if I was buying one,
I'd definitely go
for the 16 for myself.
I use a lot of the Google
services, surprisingly enough.
[LAUGH]
So a lot my data's
in the cloud.
Yeah, all my music's in Google
music and Spotify, so it's not
much local.
It's the 11 hour flight to San
Francisco, to go to my
interview will be where
you use it the most.
RICH: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
AL SUTTON: And then the Google
Play services have rolled out
into more countries,
or are rolling
out into more countries.
So you can buy movies and do
things like that, aren't they?
RICH: Yeah, music's coming,
movies coming.
Movie purchases are
coming, sorry, we
already have movie rentals.
AL SUTTON: That's
just brilliant.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so music's
coming over?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that got
announced on Monday as well.
It might have got missed in the
slew of announcements, but
music is coming to UK, Germany,
France, Italy--
RICH: We can check, but yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Can't remember.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH: Europe.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, its good.
I'm really pleased.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
can be amazing.
I just can't wait for that.
I see a lot of the promotions
that go on in Google music on
the US side, and some of the
promotions are insanely good.
And I wish I could buy them,
and then I press it, and it
doesn't work.
NICK BUTCHER: So especially if
you guys, like us, are kind of
moving between devices fairly
often, then, yeah, you don't
have to have the pain
of moving all your
music over or whatever.
It just follows you around.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean, I've had
the cloud bit for a while,
because I'd signed
up via proxy.
RICH: Ah, sneaky.
[INAUDIBLE]
What were you going
to say, sorry?
AUDIENCE: No, go on.
RICH: I always have this play
list called offline on my
Google Music, and whenever I
sign into a new device, that's
the one I just pin it offline.
And then, if I'm on the web, or
on any device, and I move
anything into the offline Play
list, it instantly syncs down
to all my devices.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
RICH: It's kind of cool.
So if you buy a new track, I
just set it to be in the
playlist offline because I go
on the London Underground a
lot, I need offline music.
So I can always set my playlist
up, which is fun.
OK, Al says he's just read the
blog post, and Google Play
Music is heading to UK, France,
Germany, Italy, Spain
this November.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool, Spain.
That's what I missed.
RICH: Yes.
Do we have anything left
in the Moderator?
SPARKY RHODE: I don't know what
happened while I was offline.
RICH: I'm just looking now.
There's one about
a chronometer.
"I would like to use Roboto
light for the chronometer, but
it seems the width for zero in
light differs from the others
[? digits ?].
Hence, there's some
shifting when
chronometer passes zeroes.
Is there anyway to solve this
problem other than using
another font?" I have
the same issue.
I've been redoing a Chronometer
style application
recently, and I get a wiggle
in the time when I'm using
Roboto light.
So yeah, you can change
the font.
You can choose not just
have it centered.
If [? you fix ?] the position.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Wiggle
is a feature.
RICH: Wiggle is a feature.
It drives me insane.
I'm not quite to sure.
You know that it's
not fixed-width.
NICK BUTCHER: You could ask
Christian why it's not fixed
width, or should it
be fixed width.
It's open source.
You could edit the glyphs,
make it fixed width.
RICH: Especially if
it's just zero.
I didn't know which
character it was
that doing the shifting.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I'm not sure
if it's basically fixed
width or not.
RICH: Can you see it shifting?
Can you see that bright light?
At what point is it going to
decide that this isn't all
just white.
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, the
wiggle the wiggle.
RICH: The wiggle, oh my god.
Sneak preview of the new
ultimate stop watch and timer
coming soon to the Play Store.
[INAUDIBLE] this is brilliant.
Thank you very much, Marie.
Well, we're out questions
from the
Moderator, as far as I know.
NICK BUTCHER: And Patrick says
yeah, what is the benefit of
Google Play Music.
Right now, nothing.
RICH: Well, I wouldn't
say that.
I would say it drives users
into the Play Store, where
they will also find
your applications.
NICK BUTCHER: That's true.
RICH: It increases traffic to
the place where your apps are.
NICK BUTCHER: More users with
forms of payment on record.
So it's easier for you to buy
your apps, this is true.
RICH: But if you're asking,
directions, creation, APIs,
things like that, there
aren't any.
NICK BUTCHER: There's no APIs,
or affiliate schemes, or
anything like that.
SPARKY RHODE: It's certainly
true that, several times a
week, I go to Google Play, and
I look at music, and it says,
get music for free.
And I click on music for free
and it says, Google Play Music
is not available in
your country.
And I say, OK, fine, I'll go
download an app instead.
RICH: [LAUGH]
NICK BUTCHER: Can you use it
to release the original
soundtrack from your game, yeah,
there's a scheme where
can sign up to sell the music
that you made, your own, yeah.
Much like you can as an app
developer, there is a similar
thing for musicians.
RICH: Yeah, you can share music
with people for free.
You can ask people
to buy music.
There's a good ecosystem
inside Google
Music for all of that.
Any other questions?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
you're right.
There are benefits
to a developer.
Yeah, it's that whole mall thing
we're trying to develop
with Google Play.
We're trying to make Google Play
this place you go to buy
valuable content.
And I think it's like a training
thing for users, so
people get used to going there,
and spending money, and
having a trusted, paid
relationship with the store.
And I think that's a really
good thing for developers.
So yeah, I was a bit too
flippant before.
RICH: Actually, I haven't been
checking the comments thread.
So I'll just have a quick look
to see if anyone's posted any
questions on Google+.
"Can you recommend a Bluetooth
keyboard for Nexus 10?" I
haven't tried any, sorry.
I have tried a Wacom tablet,
and that worked very nicely
with markers.
But I haven't tried--
SPARKY RHODE: If anybody hasn't
tried it, and you get
the chance, try out the
gesture typing.
It's magical.
NICK BUTCHER: If by anyone,
you mean, you or us.
RICH: All the people that don't
get access to it for
next couple of weeks haven't
tried it yet.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, even on the
10 inch tablet, which is
perfectly big enough for touch
typing, the gestures still
work wonderfully.
NICK BUTCHER: I love the fact
that you don't have to switch
keyboard or anything
like that.
Because when I have two hands,
I thumb, I tap out.
And then when I have
one hand, I swipe.
AL SUTTON: There's a really meta
question in the comments,
"How do I post questions?"
RICH: I saw that.
[LAUGH]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH: Yeah, no, I think he's
asking about where
this chat stream is.
Of course, it's inside the
Hangout, so people from
outside cant see it.
We always try and read
those questions out.
But you can ask questions
in the Moderator at
developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
NICK BUTCHER: Slash bleh.
RICH: Or in the comment thread
that you just asked the
question in.
SPARKY RHODE: More specifically,
that URL that
Rich said, and then
find this event.
And put it in the Moderator
for this event.
RICH: Jamie was asking, maybe
he missed it , actually,
because he joined 14 minutes in
about the "Will the cache
directory from multiple user
accounts get external cache
directory?"
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you're
doing the right thing, and you
getting all the system calls to
get the directories, then
it should just work
transparently to you.
SPARKY RHODE: And they'
not shared, right?
NICK BUTCHER: No, yeah, it'd
be individual per user.
RICH: "When does [INAUDIBLE]
come for the Galaxy Nexus?"
YOSSI ELKRIEF: So basically,
only the external storage is
shared between users?
NICK BUTCHER: No,
the whole world.
The whole everything.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH: No one know about the
release date of Galaxy Nexus.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we can't
comment on release dates for
Galaxy Nexus because
we don't know.
But typically, what's happened
in the past is, it tends to be
a couple of weeks.
Like, older devices will tend
to get an OTA a couple weeks
after the new devices
go onsale.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, basically,
let the dust
settle on the new stuff.
Because--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so 4.1 came
out with the Nexus 7 in
Google I/O, and then it was,
what, a couple of weeks
[INAUDIBLE]
before it OTA'd to the
Galaxy Nexus, I
mean, that's been typical.
But I don't know
RICH: Most of these devices also
have wired HDMI out of
some sort or another, as
well as the Miracast.
The Nexus 10 has a micro
HDMI slot on the side.
And the Nexus 4 is using--
NICK BUTCHER: Simport.
RICH: Yeah, sim variety of
display port, which adapters
appear to be appearing on
Amazon at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh cool, actually,
because the HDMI MHL
adapters always have to powered
to be powered, right?
You always have to plug in a
power source as well as an
HDMI, whereas I believe the
Slimport doesn't require the
power, so it's just
an adapter.
RICH: It doesn't require the
power, but it still has power
socket on, so you can still
charge your phone whilst it's
plugged in, which is probably
a good idea.
But yeah, cool, the one
that I've seen so far.
So I'll be picking one
of those up for
presentations soon.
NICK BUTCHER: Another
dongle to buy.
RICH: Another dongle to buy.
And a new TV to buy, with
Miracast support because I
don't want to stick
[INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: It just blows my
mind to think of using a phone
to drive pictures onto
my 42 inch TV.
RICH: Yeah, those
TVs are pretty
high-res these days, right.
SPARKY RHODE: We are so
living in the future.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm so excited
about the two-screen API.
I think it's going to
drive a whole bunch
of interesting apps.
RICH: I totally agree.
The two-screen API, absolutely
awesome for gaming, for apps,
presentation, even YouTube.
Even YouTube.
All these things can benefit a
lot from dual-screen APIs.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, the API
hasn't been released yet, but
if you want to start thinking
about it, basically, you'll
see the second screen is going
to be a bit like a dialogue.
So your app completely
contains it.
It's not like you can have one
thing going on in one screen
and running, [INAUDIBLE] they
are entirely linked, so your
app owns, like, a dialogue which
is on the big screen.
So start thinking about that,
how you might draw to another
dialogue, as it were.
And that will have
its own context.
So it will load the right
resolution, durable, and
things for the screen size, and
whatever of the TV it's
running on.
AL SUTTON: Is there any
compatibility layer for Google
TV's second screen API?
NICK BUTCHER: Second screen
API is just for passing
intents and saying, go
run this, right?
It doesn't actually do a
companion app type thing.
I think it's a different
problem with a
similar name, I think.
Matt?
RICH: [LAUGH]
Virtual Matt Android.
We should have him dialed in.
I forgot to thank the guys at
Sony, Sony developers, for
giving me this T-shirt
at DroidCon as well.
Android Attacks, dum dum dum.
Thank you very much, Sonny--
NICK BUTCHER: For that
terrifying T-shirt.
It's kind of Halloween, right?
We've got Halloween
theme going on all
over the office today.
So a big Android crushing
cities, I don't know, seem to
work for me.
And with that, it's the end
of this week's Hangout.
Thank you all for joining.
We will see you again next
Wednesday, 2 PM.
We're slightly shifted out of
the US time zone right now
because they change
their clocks at
different time to us.
NICK BUTCHER: So catch them in
seven hours, I guess, right?
RICH: Perhaps in seven hours.
And have a good week.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Thanks guys.
AUDIENCE: Yeah guys,
bye, thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: Cheers.